وربما هي كمان البلاد
تحظى تحظى غالبا
بقامات يعني مثقفه
ومحبي
وليس مديحا فيك يعني يعني انت وقت اللي
اتيت الى وزاره الثقافه قبل حوالي عشرين
سنه تقريبا في سنه 98 يعني اكثر من 20 سنه
يعني لمساتك لم تزل قائمه حتى الان على
مشاريع مشاريع التنمويه وثقافيه بمعظم
المدن المغربي ماذا اساس يعني اذا لم يكن
المناضل والسياسي مثقفا اظن لا يستطيع ان
يعمل اضافي حتى لو احتل الموقع مهما كان
عظيما هذه المنطقه في مجال الثقافه اظن ان
الاهم هو ان يكون المسؤول على قدر من
الاهتمام بالانتاج الفكري الفني لبلده وان
لا يكون مجرد مدبر اداري او مدبر مالي
مثلا في فرنسا في عهد تولى حقيبه وزاره
الثقافه جاك لانك معروف انه هو جامعي اقرب
للتاريخ لكن هو في نفس الوقت كان ايضا
مسؤول في مدينه افينيو عن مهرجان
من هذا المطلق كان اهتمامه بالمجال
الثقافي اهتمام مستهلك ذكي يعرف
مختلف الانتاجات الفنيه
والادبيه في فرنسا ويتابعها عن قرب لذلك
نجح فيه في
مهمته الى بعض الحدود هاد الجانب اظن
ضروري في مسؤوليه
والسمات الذي يحتلها هذا الموقع نعم بس
انت تعرف ايضا انه اليوم الثقافه ليست فقط
الانتاج الفني والادبي ولكن هي ايضا
صناعات
لتدبيرها يجب التوفر على طاقات مهمه هناك
ما يسمى في الغرب اليوم بالاقتصاد الثقافي
نتحول الى هذا المسار لابد من اطر تسير
الثقافه بطريقه اقتصاديه وليس فقط
الاستثمار في الثقافه يعني
المهرجانات اللي في المغرب نوع من
الاستثمار
ومسحورات
والحفاظ على التراث وتقديمه كمنتج سياحي
هذا مساهمه كبيره في تنميه المجتمعات نعم